hello everybody and welcome to episode
12 of my pay to play flipping series
we're gonna go from zero to hundred mil
using the Koran exchange only so today
ever starting off at about 12 mil we're
on day ten so we have quite a bit left
our membership still sorry I haven't
made one of these episodes in a couple
days I've just been kind of busy with
some other video ideas but we'll make
sure to get these out still okay let's
get started so first up I think we're
gonna do the dragon mace it has about 3k
margins on it and I think buying limit
is 70 which we give us about 200 15k
assuming we buy and sell them all which
is pretty good I also go ahead and buy I
think 70 of these and we'll get them for
about now let's see 33 500 about maybe a
little less 2 3 4 20 and we'll do 70 and
next up we might do the chocolate dust
which actually has a 26 GPA Arjun on it
and it is a very cheap item some a
little confused about that but hopefully
they ought to buy and sell I think the
limit is something like 10,000 removed
13,000 I supposed to pretty high buying
limit now let's see if we actually get
this money for this price will be
interesting because they are quite lower
than they normally are and for the last
item here I think we're gonna do the
Paschal rune which has worked pretty
well in the past again it has a 60 P
margin on it which is quite good and I
think the violin is 10 K for the actual
runes but I should know I tested myself
but a 10 K or 12 came either way we'll
be making probably 60 to 80 K which
would be nice the flips are in and we
did quite well on most of the items
we'll start with the Asheville runes
that are simple as that we only got 1 GP
on the Asheville room 2 only given this
10 K for that and these super energy
potions we got a 407 GP margin on and
2000 those that's well 815 K from that
and the chocolate dust we've got 7 GP on
each one and 13 K which surprised me and
we actually got them all so it's 91 K
from a chocolate desk which is really
good for the cost of the item and we're
still in the process of selling the each
dragon maces so once again that's like a
1 mil flip the bulk of that it's the
energy potion but we will not talk about
that too much okay so we're gonna try
flipping the mud rune I had a pretty
good margin on you can see there um
I had a 600 GP margin on it I believe
which is definitely not right but we're
gonna go ahead and try buy some of these
anyway I doubt we'll be able to sell any
of them for 910 but you never know you'd
be surprised how many people just jack
up the price just to get that thought
quickly so they might make a mistake so
we'll go ahead and do the mic room and
we're also gonna put an offer in for
this random new item - dark bowtie I
don't know it's possible people might
just be dumping these because they don't
want them so the the G price is 5 mil
but we're gonna put in forward 1.2 mil
it's just kind of shot in the dark and
see what happens pretty much ok so the
flips are in and a little messy but we
did pretty good so the dragon maces we
had to calculates we sold it into
different groups but we made about 50k
off the dragon minutes that's not so bad
but not that great and the energy
potions we got and this her 217 GP
margin given us 434 K the mushrooms are
still in the process of selling but we
are getting a decent profit on them and
the dark bowtie we didn't end up buying
so whatever the mud rooms we'll just
have to sell for probably cheaper price
we're gonna pull them out but we should
still be making a decent profit on them
as well okay so first stuff we might do
some bolt racks just kinda randomly
trying some different items it had a six
GP margin on them and they must be sold
quite a lot I think over a couple
million a day at least so we're gonna
buy them for 83 and double by the buying
limit which i think is still 11,000 or
maybe it's 13,000 but whatever and last
year we're gonna do another super
defense potion haven't done these a
little while soul pops in here but it
has a pretty decent margin on it
we're going to bed so we're gonna see if
can buy 4,000 of them overnight okay so
we have sold everything and once again
things are a little bit messy just cuz
it an all sell in one chunk but just to
explain it
start the bolt racks that was pretty
easy we got four GP on each one and
11,000 of those
that's that's 44 k I had the super
defenses we got 827 GP margin on them
and we got just over a thousand of those
that's a hundred and forty 6k the mud
rooms we've sold in two different clumps
added together in calculated we made
about 97 K in the mud runes I've got
pretty decent margin on the first two
thousand in a pretty
which one and then the last 7,000 I
given us but 97k which is pretty good
for a rune so yeah let's go find it with
more items so I think we're gonna
actually do some crystal keys again it
looks like it has over a 1000 GB margin
per key which is pretty good so we're
gonna have to go just put the two offers
and again for the loop half of the heat
and the 2008 we've about 7.1 milla left
so we should be able to get a couple
hundred of these so the two halves we're
gonna put in for just over 30 K now
which is definitely a bit lower than
normally our household try 180 and for
the tooth - all right they're much lower
than they normally are I know stare down
to like 0.1 cares I'm now a 4/5 but
still quite a bit lower than that I've
seen them in the past
either way this still adds up to over 1k
profit on each Keith and we've got
perfectly 180 okay well let's come back
when these have BOTS okay so we have two
flips coming in here but they're very
good ones um so the energy potions again
we got a 227 GP margin on them and 2455
k it's pretty good and the crystal keys
we still managed to get a 1.5 k margin
each one which is actually quite good I
had more money and bought more keys that
would have made some serious Bank but we
can only afford a hundred eighty keys
but 101.5 k times 180 keys is 265 k so
that's still really nice that we're
getting quite a bit profit and this week
so yeah let's try keep it going okay so
I think we're gonna do the crystal keys
again they still seem to have about a
1.5 k margin on them so if I was
actually able to invest most of my money
in this I would be getting quite a lot
huh so we've already put an offer in for
the 2004 30 and 1gb and so for the loop
pass will do another 250 of those and
hopefully we can keep our 1.5 key margin
and get about three or 400 K from this
and I think just to use the rest of our
money we're gonna put the offer into the
air orbs they seem to have is 38 GP
margin which is not too bad and that for
how frequently they're traded as well go
ahead and buy probably I'm looking
forward maybe 10,000 and sorry nice more
like 3,000 okay so I'm a little weird
happened we kind of got the crystal key
split up but uh apparently the tooth
half of the keys have crashed quite a
bit but we'll go through this first I'll
start the arrow or because I was easy we
actually did get a 45 GP margin them in
3000 though gives us 135 km profit now
the crystal keys I broke it up because
we actually kind of lost money in them
to be on we got the crystal keys about
129 of them made and we didn't get about
nine or GP profit on them how would she
give us and earn 18k but the tooth half
of the keys that we had left over
because they only managed to buy 129 of
the loop half so we can only combine
that many keys so we had the boat and a
130 or something to half of keys left
over and those sold at quite a large
loss of 2.6 K each so we lost 159 km/h /
no all we lost a bit money on the keys
but you can see here in the background
the tooth halves have dropped down to
25k each so we're gonna go ahead and buy
a bunch of these and try to get our
money back so we're gonna put them in
for 25k and ten coins so theoretically
every single tooth half of Kiwi buy we
should be in five K Oh which is quite a
lot so put an offer in for that and hope
it completes so the original plan was to
find another item but these are coming
through quite quickly I'm just gonna put
another offer in just in case we do hits
the 250 limit or 250 keys that we have
in our other offer slot
I will go put another 250 in because
this is a good opportunity to make some
serious money actually but with the rest
of our money we may actually put another
offer and for the fire orbs it a pretty
decent margin on them and the orbs do
buy and sell pretty quickly so we'll do
1200 orbs not 12 will do 1200 and we'll
come back when the keys have
sold okay so we are back and we managed
to get 117 mm I would have been awesome
if we had managed to get more but
obviously not that many people were
selling them at that price because they
don't really feel like it but still on
the hundred and seventeen Keys we did
get now we got about five k margin I
given us 643 K pretty good we easily
made up any of the losses from the last
flip and the fire orbs again pretty
small but we got thirty GP on them each
and 1200 goodness 36 k I spoke about 700
K in total from that flip so pretty nice
so we started this episode at about 212
mill on the dot and we are going to be
finishing it at 15.1 mills we made over
three million we're starting to make a
lot more progress as our cash sack gets
a bit higher and we still eight days
left on our membership so maybe we get
to 20 mil who knows
I will try our best so thanks for
watching guys I hope you enjoyed and we
will see you guys in episode 13